[Music]
am i audible now you are ready
okay i was telling hi to everyone that i
wasn't getting any response okay
hi kavita hi sarupa vishwa hi sandeep
how are you guys
hi how are you i'm good
hi youtube welcome hi rudy so nice to be
here
yeah how are you doing i'm doing great
how are you
i'm good good we may start the session
in 10 minutes as soon as others join
thank you
hi netra how are you good to have you
over here
hi finally
yes
so nadia can we please make urja and
nitra as
the co-host
so nadika can you hear me can you please
make urja
and nitra as co-host so that we can
start with the session
okay so hello and welcome everybody i
warmly welcome you to the
session of cyanics club titled
applying transcriptomics gene expression
data analysis
for neuroscience project so
for the presenters today we have
urja parikh she was omixlogic research
fellow in 2020
she did her bs in biomedical sciences
from
svkms managem mongi institute of
management studies
the project she did was differential
identification of biomarkers between
normal neural stem cells and
glioblastoma stem cells
after completing her project she went
ahead and published her paper the
picture you can see over here so
i warmly welcome you urja and the second
presenter for today
is nitra srinivasan she was also a
mixologic research fellow in 2020 she is
a student at leland high school
and the project title is effects of
onset of menopause on transcriptomics
profiling of female brain
so first udra will present followed by
naitra's presentation but before
starting with the presentations i would
like to brief you all about
what cyanics club is so cyanx is a
bioinformatics and data science student
club
which is a joint initiative taken by
students associated with pine biotech
our main goal is to help students learn
about bioinformatics research via group
sessions
easy to take courses debates and
discussions we not only do this but also
aim to encourage young minds to push
their critical thinking limits beyond
the school and college curriculum
i am rudy raja president of cyanomix
club
and also serving as a campus ambassador
at pine biotech
i am an undergraduate third year student
of integrated biomedical
sciences for the last session in the
last week we did an astrobiology session
which was again presented by our
research fellows that the shubrajeet
and the lara de ken they presented the
projects on astrobiology
for today's session we i as already
discussed we have urja and natra to
present on neuroscience project uses
using transcriptomics gene expression
data analysis
for further on what do we do in our
weekly ceramics club meeting is that we
have interactive zoom sessions
we have debates and we discuss certain
kinds of
review report writing or certain kinds
of crucial health topics which could be
important in bioinformatics big data
analysis
so our main goal is to provide training
in bioinformatics
enable independent research that is
guided by mentors and peer example
not only this but we also wish to
develop a growing community full of
students researchers and even mentors
for the data driven research and
appreciation of science citizen science
we also help enable students clinicians
and faculties of
all the backgrounds of life sciences and
bioinformatics to develop
novel and independent research projects
using latest technology in life and data
sciences
cover topics like infectious diseases
neuroscience
plant science prescription oncology
microbes and microbiome
this helps us to apply the knowledge of
application of big data into biology
not only this but we also help students
clear
basic concepts of bioinformatics in our
weekly sessions
we help them to gain insight onto how to
use the tools of
bioinformatics by demonstrating live
hands-on experiments
we also help them understand the
applications of coding in bioinformatics
and certain specific
experience on data science skill sets
so for to begin with your journey for
cyanics
club and with pine biotech you need to
make an account on omixlogic whose link
would be shortly shared in the chat box
once you this is like a home page of
omics logic where you need to enter your
email id and then the password
we also have social groups on psionics
club that is on slack channel
we have omics logic groups on linkedin
and also on facebook the links will be
shared in the chat box
moving on we also provide free courses
that is introduction to bioinformatics
and introduction to genomics
these are self-learning courses easy to
take without paying
anything and one can learn the basics of
bioinformatics by enrolling themselves
into these course
furthermore we also offer premium
courses like bioinformatics machine
learning
genomics transcriptomics meta genomics
and machine learning
so these are premium courses which you
have to pay some amount in order to
learn but we provide these courses at
very cheap rates
and they are very useful if you want to
get started with bioinformatics
we also have group discussions as talked
about in which we have to bet on
mind-boggling arenas and certain crucial
topics in bioinformatics
we have presentations by phd scholars
research fellows of
all their research work or their
published work
and we also have scientific discussions
and debates in order to exchange the
ideas for project
development and further research and
development
as told you can connect with us on the
slack channel
that is the psionics channel over here
we help
everyone to get know about the latest
upcoming events
webinars and everything we also have
linkedin group for
pine biotech where we post about most of
the upcoming sessions
and webinars we also have our telegram
group in which we talk about
the upcoming members upcoming webinars
and everything
and for the slack channel we also have
omics logic research fellowship slack
channel in which we discuss the
technical criteria of the project
so everyone who is doing a research or
is a research fellow associated with
find biotech
can join this omix logic research
fellowship slack channel in which we
discuss the technical part of it if
someone is having any problems
encountering in their
way of project and further on and how to
join the ceramics club this is the
whatsapp group link you can
you join the club using this whatsapp
group link and also we welcome all the
agents because we think that knowledge
has no boundaries
thank you very much for listening this
patiently
i mean right now urja to share her
screen and start with her presentation
ujja over to you thank you
thank you so much ritri for that kind
introduction
and um i'm so happy to see how much uh
fine bio has grown and siomix is a great
initiative
um to spread information about
bioinformatics um
and i can personally attest to the fact
that bioinformatics is extremely useful
in biology
and it will take every student ahead
in their academic future so it will put
you at the top
amongst other students so um i'll share
my screen now
and i hope my presentation is visible
yes urjah it is visible thank you okay
so um last year i was a research fellow
with pine biotech
um and the title of my project was
different initially but
this is the final title with which uh we
have also released our treatment
which is in silicon analysis and
characterization of differentially
expressed genes
to distinguish glioma stem cells from
normal human stem cells
so it it sounds quite complex but i will
yeah just a minute i'm so sorry to
interrupt can you just on your video
because we are live
on youtube okay sure thank you
hold on a second
okay i hope i'm visible yes good to go
awesome right
okay right so i will break down uh
the aspects of this research project for
you all to understand
uh but before i proceed i'll just speak
a little bit about myself
i recently completed my master's in
biomedical science from
school of science which is a part of the
animals university in mumbai
i'm currently working at a hospital in
mumbai which is kokila bayla by ambani
hospital
and i'm involved in several research
projects here
i'm also a visiting research fellow at
blue marble space institute of science
uh i'm working remotely at the moment
and this
particular non-profit organization is
based out of
the us so um
coming to my research underwater in 2016
i began my undergrad studies in
biomedical science where
i was introduced to vast areas of
biology including neurobiology cell
biology molecular biology
by a lot of these subjects
and um it was neuroscience that uh
really
elicited my interest so after that
in 2018 i interned at st
viewers college which is again in mumbai
where i
was involved in two research projects in
one i
identified two novel strains of least
and characterized them and in the other
i created a puc 18 vector which has a
team binding domain from yeast
uh in my final year of graduation
undergrad i also synthesize
nanoparticles using a plant extract
in 2020 um i had actually lost a very
important research fellowship which was
supposed to happen in canada and that's
when i
actually searched for pine biotech and i
remotely interned with them for the
period of three months and that's when i
performed this particular analysis and
now
i'm working at uh particular being
bambani hospital as i said
where i have completed my master's
thesis and i'm working on establishing
two proteins s100b and gfap as
biomarkers for diseases like
intracellular hematoma and traumatic
brain injury
i've also established a machine learning
algorithm that diagnoses acute kidney
injury in patients
um and now further i also wish to pursue
a phd
so coming to my project um please feel
free to
ask me any questions in the chat i will
come back to those uh
after the presentation is done so let's
talk about glioblastoma multiform which
is
gbm um this particular type of brain
cancer is a primary brain tumor which is
extremely malignant
extremely aggressive um and a patient
who gets this particular type of cancer
has
an overall survival period of only 15
months post therapy
so um it's difficult uh to
increase their survival time and that is
mostly going to
um the etiology of this cancer so
scientists still don't know where this
cancer is arising from
all right so we know the uh place which
is the subventricular zone in the brain
uh where these particular type of
cancers usually originate but how
is what is unknown so currently there
are two hypotheses
uh that tell us about the origin of
glioblastoma
one states that normal neural stem cells
can accumulate mutations
undergo transformation and form this
particular type of cancer
the second hypothesis states that cancer
stem cells
are tumor initiative cells uh that may
directly
cause the origin of this particular type
of cancer so now this particular these
two hypotheses have been widely debated
since years it is also important to
understand that cancer stem cells
also impart radio resistance and chemo
resistance in these particular types of
cancers so glioblastoma
is popularly known for its recurrence so
after the first tumor has been treated
the tumor tends to relapse and come back
again
and these particular types of secondary
tumors are more radio resistant
and therefore difficult to treat so
what is as i said what is unknown is
what are the differences or what are the
similarities between cancer stem cells
and in this case we will further the
cancers themselves gliomas themselves
also also abbreviated as gse
so are glioma stem cells similar to
normal neural stem cells or are they
different
um it is essential to understand the
differences between these two types of
stem cells
because if we identify genetic and
epigenetic differences
we can also understand what exactly is
the reason why glioblastoma is malignant
and we can also target particular
proteins or genes
that may be the most important in
driving this particular type of cancer
so using precision medicine we will be
able to improve therapeutic efficacy
and therefore in order to answer the
question whether they are similar or
different
we have performed rna sleep analysis to
identify the genetic differences between
uh normally on stem cells and biomass
themselves
so how have we done this the first step
in rna seep analysis is to collect
data because of course this is not a
wetland project this is
done on a computer so we have to find
existing databases
and existing data sets to perform our
experiment
uh so there is um a website or a
database which is called
geogeo which is a part of ncbi
so on this particular database you get
it's a depository of rna sequences
where you get different types of rna
samples rna sequence samples of
different types of cancers
or different types of organisms so you
go on this particular database and you
have to go
through multiple projects to see which
one fits your criteria the best
so i fortunately found a great data data
set of rla sequences
in which the person had
isolated rna sequence from glioma stem
cells as well as normal neural stem
cells
so that the particular code for this
particular data set was gsc1c2172
which you can actually go check on the
internet
now they had a sample size of 188
samples however
because the data is too large we only
selected 40 samples 28 gliomas stem
cells and 20 of normal humans themselves
the next step is to uh take this rna
sequence and make sense of
it and we do that using rna seep
analysis
right so we analyze data using certain
pipelines
so uh this entire analysis has been done
on the pine biotech
platform so what you essentially do is
you take the rna sequence that you
obtained from the internet
and you align these particular rna
sequences
to the human genome at the end of this
you get
the gene counts of every gene that has
been expressed in
either glioma stem cells and normal
neural stem cells and after that
in order to understand how differently
certain genes are expressed
in these two types of stem cell samples
you perform differential
gene expression analysis and for that
you use a pipeline called dc2
so this is like the general idea of what
rna seek analysis is
then once you have got the abundance of
gene
uh expression in these two types of
samples and once you know
how differently they are expressed in
these two types of stem cells you have
to perform gene ontology studies
which basically means that uh you have
um identified certain genes that are of
importance but you need to understand
what their functions are
uh so i will of course be talking about
more about this in more detail
so coming to the results so after
performing the rna feed pipeline as i
already showed you all
uh we started with a total of 27 385
genes at the beginning
uh which were enriched in these two
types of stem cells now this is a large
it's a huge number of genes so we have
to uh
set certain thresholds to identify the
most significant genes that may be
playing a role in driving this
particular type of cancer
so after you perform differential gene
expression analysis that gives you an
idea of what
genes are upregulated and downregulated
in these stem cells
you have to choose the significance
value which is usually lesser than 0.05
and you have to also look at the log 2
full change value
so this uh is basically an indicator of
the abundance of gene expression
uh so for this a particular project we
have kept it uh greater than three for
git and lesser than minus three for nfcs
i'll be explaining that further
so from 27 385 genes we finally came
down to the top
50 most significant genes that might be
involved in
driving glioblastoma multiple so
once you have got the gene expression
from or the gene abundance from the rna
seek analysis the first step that you
have to do
is uh principle component component
analysis which is a type of
dimensionality reduction
um where you i so basically in these
graphs
you can see the glioma stem cells and
normally your stem cells have
separated and clustered quite apart from
each other which basically
shows that these two types of stem cells
are indeed
different in terms of their genetic
expression
right so that was a first clue that
normal you know stem cells and gliomas
themselves are actually genetically
different
to confirm these findings we also
perform the type of
machine learning algorithm which is
hierarchical clustering
over here again we confirm that normally
stem cells cluster together glioma stem
cells cluster together
we also found an important outlier
sample
now this outline sample was actually a
glioma stem cell sample
which actually clustered in between
normal stem cells and glioma stem cells
um we believe that this particular
outlier sample might be an important
clue about how normal neural stem cells
can actually transform to glioma stem
cells
because it technically lies in between
uh and
it might be uh giving us hints about the
transformation process of stem
like a normal use stem cells to a
cancerous phenotype
the next thing that we did was perform
differential gene expression analysis
and uh
like after you run the pipeline you get
uh several types of graphs
so one of them is a volcano plot that
you can see on this particular slide
so you can see these dots that are in
blue
so they are genes that are highly
expressed in
either types of stem cell samples so um
as you can see there are so many genes
not all of them are the most significant
ones
so as i already mentioned to you all
that we have to
choose the most significant ones and for
that we use the p adjusted value
which is which is supposed to be lesser
than 0.05
and we also look at the log to full
change value which tells us
what are the most um abundantly uh
differentially
expressed genes right so um over here
supposing you take normal neural stem
cells you see s hundred a 11 ubb
mgst1 serpent f1 so these are the most
abundantly differentially expressed
genes that you may find in normal neural
stem cells and similarly in glioma stem
cells you have s hundred b x under a6
crb1
which are more important candidates so
by setting these particular thresholds
we
identified 192 genes that were
significantly upregulated in glioma stem
cells and 156 genes
that was significantly downregulated in
glioma stem cells in comparison to
normal neural stem cells
so that is in total we had 348 gene
candidates
that may be important in driving glioma
genesis
so what do you do of these 348 genes
right so that's when gene ontology comes
in
so what we did was we took these
particular gene sets
that we had obtained from differential
gene expression analysis and loaded it
on
um david and geg so these two are
online repositories again where you can
upload your gene data
and it will provide you details about
where your genes are involved in what
kind of diseases
in what kind of cell signaling pathways
what exactly is the function of the
genes that you have got in your subject
so what i saw with my results was that
the genes that i had identified were
mostly
enriched in diseases such as alzheimer's
schizophrenia adhd
autism myocardial infarction but there
was no involvement of these particular
genes
with biliomagnesis which gives give
which gave us the first hint that uh the
genes that we have obtained
in our study are novel and their
indication in glioma genesis
has still not been studied so
um okay so over here you see that there
are
several uh pathways in which our genes
have been
involved so the ones that you can see
with the
star marked in red so these ankyl
is one protein that was found in my
particular gene list
which was shown to be enriched in the
glioma stem cells
so this particular protein and iron is
responsible for cell growth migration
proliferation
um then we had sdc4 and alpha 2 beta 1
which is an integrin
which are responsible for angiogenesis
again and migration and proliferation
pathways
other integrins that were again involved
in tumor cell and invasion pathways
we saw the wind protein that was
enriched in a particular data set which
is
again responsible for proliferation and
survival of tumor cells
the wedges which is one of the most uh
common
uh angiogenesis factors that drives uh
tumor promotion
so we saw all these particular genes
were uh involved in
our particular gene cells again we had
tgf beta pathways so we had genes like
lumifan and cavulin which were
involved which drive apoptosis and
growth suppression which may be
upregulated or down regulated or mutated
in our particular types of stem cell
samples
so overall this basically shows that the
genes
that we obtained in our study are
identified in our study
are involved in several tumor genesis
pathways you might be knowing that uh
there are certain hallmarks of cancers
and these particular hallmarks of
cancers
are pathways by which tumors evade say
the immune cells or the continued growth
so
we have a clear indication that the
genes in my study are
involved in the hallmarks of cancers
so again 348 genes that we considered in
our study were again
too many so we again need to identify
the most important ones
so what i did was i filtered the only
top 15 most highly differentially
expressed genes
right so the ones that are more
abundantly expressed in either normal
stem cells of glioma stem cells those
are the ones that i considered
for further literature review
again using those top 50 genes that i
selected i again carried out principle
component analysis and saw
but the separation of gliomas stem cells
and normal neural stem cells
is still vast and therefore they differ
significantly
considering these 50 genes and their
expression
and uh that the genes that are
upregulated in glioma stem cells are
down regulated in normal legal stem
cells
and the ones that are upregulated in
normal stem cells that are negated in
glioma stem cells which you can see in
this heat map
so uh then what i did was i performed
the literature review of those 50 genes
and what i saw was that uh while we had
identified several candidates which have
an already known association in glioma
genocide
for example s100b s100a6 gpnb
which were upregulated in glioma stem
cells uh and there were genes like s
hundred a11 updates open f1 which were
down regulated in glioma stem cells
these genes have already been studied by
scientists
and have unknown uh involvement in this
particular type of cancer
but more importantly we have we found
genes
that have still no known studies
performed and
uh are actually if we study it more we
will actually find they are involved in
glioma genesis
so these genes which have no previous
known association with gluogenesis are
itm2a
box one we also found several
unidentified genes so these are
completely normal genes
which have still not been discovered by
scientists so these particular genes
actually need to be
um studied in more detail by people who
are working in labs
and identify their roles in glioma
genesis
so to conclude my findings i identify
348 significantly differentially
expressed genes in glioma stem cells and
normal neural stem cells
right with a stringent threshold values
these genes that i found in my pathways
were involved in
hallmarks of cancers like tgf beta wind
signaling and angiogenesis pathways
i identified several genes that have
more known association with glioma
genesis and therefore
are very good candidates to study in
order to understand
better how this cancer progresses in the
brain
um i believe that future studies on
these particular candidates
um can reveal important targets for
therapy so they can act as good
biomarkers for either diagnosis or
prognosis
or they can be targeted by a precision
medicine
finally the outlier sample that i
mentioned earlier
i think having more studies on that
particular type of samples would reveal
hints
regarding how normally your stem cells
can transform to
glioma stem cells or directly to the
cancerous phenotype
uh so yeah so those were the results of
my studies and
these are just three most important
differences in my study
uh at this point i would like to
acknowledge the entire team at pine
biotech
uh dr mohit mazumdar ilya sir
um and uh who have uh been
extremely crucial in this project and uh
for their help
in supporting me throughout uh and i
would also like to thank luther and the
entire cyomics team for
um inviting me and allowing me to
present my work um
i would also like to state that um i
have
presented this particular work at
several international and national
conferences
and i have won several um awards for the
same
so yeah i think um pine biotech has been
uh so helpful in uh helping me develop
my
own uh profile my research profile and
this particular
research study has also gained a lot of
accolades uh so i believe that
all of you all should learn
bioinformatics
because it's a great feel it's a very
interesting field
and if you're ever planning to apply for
a phd bioinformatics is a very crucial
skill to have
um so yeah i hope this um
session was helpful if you all have any
questions
i can answer them now and you can always
email me
on my email id which was mentioned here
thank you
that was an amazing presentation and how
significantly you have grown makes me so
happy to see how much you have
progressed and all
so thank you so much again for
presenting i had a question
that uh what exactly does need to be
studied for that
outlier in order to see the
transformation from neural to
glioblastoma
program prognosis right
um again um that's a great question
literally
uh one thing that we have not done in
this particular study
is um look at the genetic differences in
comparison to the
uh complete tumor population right so we
have only looked at stem cell
populations
uh if we compare this particular outlier
sample
along with the normal so normal neural
stem cell sample so this particular
outlier was a glioma stem cell sample
so what we can do is correlate the
genetic findings
with the normal you know stem cell
samples as well as the glioma pheno the
actual
tumor the entire tumor instead of just
looking at the
uh stem cells with that we will be able
to see how much
uh similarity is there in the genetic
expression uh how much is it close to
the glioblastoma phenotype and how much
is it close to the normal you know stem
cell
so we will actually be able to see uh
like a progression
of uh genetic changes so if in a normal
neural stem cell a particular gene
is um not is down regulated
maybe in this particular outlier sample
it is mildly upregulated and maybe in
the cancers the entire cancerous
phenotype
uh if we compare that particular gene is
very highly upregulated
so we can actually see those kind of
differences and uh
understanding whether um is it like
a progressive behavior in the pattern of
gene expression
that is one way to study it of course
there will be other ways to study
um outlier samples which i will actually
have to
uh look into but uh i can get back to
you on that
for sure thanks urja we do have another
question from
he's asking he's telling great work and
really insightful
and he has a question that can you
please elaborate the steps you used to
find the differentially
expression of genes thank you to that
so um okay let me just go back to that
slide
yeah so see after rna sleep analysis you
get
something called a gene count table okay
so
after that you are supposed to um
i'm talking only technically what you're
supposed to do is
uh you take the gene count table and
then you have to actually normalize your
uh chain counts and you have to also
remove all the background noise that may
be there so
uh you have to quantile normalize it
after you have got
after you have processed your gene
counts you have to
basically upload those gene count data
onto the platform and you have to run
this pipeline
which is the differential gene
expression pipeline which is dc2
so what this pipeline essentially does
is uh
tells us how different is the expression
of a particular gene
in comparison to the control sample so
for example if glioma stem cell
i want to look at the expression of a
particular gene and glioma stem cell
uh my control would be a normal neural
stem cell so what happens in this
particular type of
pipeline you get how much more
is a particular gene expressed in the
glioma stem cell in comparison to normal
neural stem cells
right so um over here it's pretty
straight forward all you need to do is
uh upload your gene pounds and then run
this particular pipeline
and after that after you um
you get that particular pipeline you'll
again get like a huge
amount of data right so when you get
that data
you have to so you will get several
columns where you will have different
parameters of
each gene so if you have started with
say um
27 000 genes the after you run this
particular pipeline you will get only
those particular genes that are
differentially expressed
when there is a difference in expression
of those genes
so what you will get along with each
gene is the p
value so if your p value is greater than
0.05
then that means that the difference in
gene expression is not significant
so you have to automatically eliminate
those particular genes
then the genes that have a significance
value less than 0.05
you need to consider those again you
will still end up with a lot of genes
so again you need to filter them then
you look at the log full change value
where you see uh the genes that are the
most abundantly expressed in a
particular sample
so when you actually look at the data it
would be simpler for you to understand
what i'm saying
uh you have to select the highest values
in order to
identify only few genes that may be of
relevance i
hope i made it slightly more clear
further
one more last question we have from the
youtube
sharing so prima is asking what exactly
brain cells are transforming
into tumor cells i mean she means to
say that what types of brain cells are
transforming into tumor cells
okay so lima good question uh these are
stem cells
so glioblastoma um
currently the hypothesis are the
glioblastoma arises from stem cells
these stem cells are usually found in
the subventricular zone of the brain
right so uh even in a normal person who
does not have this cancer there are
a population of stem cells that are
present in that particular area of the
brain
um what happens in patients with
glioblastoma
these particular types of stem cells
mainly
sorry more
okay so um what i was saying was
those stem cells that are present in
that portion of the brain
can mutate and when a lot of mutations
accumulate
they can become cancerous um so that is
the current hypothesis around which we
believe that your customer arises from
i hope that answers your question
yes thank you any more questions you can
put it down in the chat box uja will
answer at the last once we finish
nitra's presentation
thank you so much urja for sharing and
we definitely have a lot to learn from
you
thank you so much for having me i look
forward to natra's presentation
sure hi nidra can you hear me
hi are you able to hear me yes natra i
am a very warm welcome over here and we
are glad to have you
thank you finally yeah so can you please
share your screen and go ahead with your
presentation
yes thank you
all right are you able to see my uh
slides
yes i just visit the all right
awesome so hello everybody thank you for
having me
uh my research project is uh
basically investigating the effects of
the onset of menopause
on the transcriptomic profile of the
aging female brain
so i am nadra srinivasan from
leland high school in san jose
california
in the us and i am interested
in bioinformatics because of the
flexibility it
provides to do biological research and
the interdisciplinary field of
bioinformatics allows me to explore data
and draw conclusions in a new way
and i've been attracted to research for
years because i'm able to
learn new things hands-on and draw
conclusions from my work which is very
satisfying to me
and i look forward to the future
research
that i do as well learning from this
experience
so to start off with the significance
of the problem so we know that there is
a divergence in the occurrence of
neurodegenerative diseases between males
and females
but the mechanisms so far are unknown
so mishra it all validated the
divergence between
human males and females through
microarray profiling
but for example more than 5.5 million
americans are living with alzheimer's
disease
of whom two-thirds are elderly women
and the mitochondria of young females
are protected
against the pathologies of alzheimer's
disease
compared to males but this advantage is
lost in older females
and moreover current alzheimer's disease
treatments only target
neurotransmitters to treat the symptoms
but not the root cause and thus it's
important
to figure out the underlying factors to
be able to better target
treatment through identifying
transcriptomic differences
to identify the genes at play and
pinpoint the pathways
for treatment so previous research has
investigated immune profiles in
menopausal rats
but the overall effects are yet to be
interpreted
and so understanding the genes expressed
differently in the progressive stages
of female aging and menopause can help
us understand risks for
neurodegeneration and pathways
to treat in order to treat
neurodegeneration such as
for alzheimer's disease in women
and so through this research doctors and
researchers will be able to take
the occurrence of menopause into account
when developing
treatments for near degenerative
diseases which significantly affects
more females than males and so to
summarize
current treatments only address the
symptoms but do not target
the root cause so therefore
understanding the genes expressed
differently in the progressive stages of
female aging and menopause
can help us understand the risks for
neurodegeneration
and pathways to treat these diseases
such as
alzheimer's disease in women more
effectively
and so through understanding that the
onset of menopause plays a role in the
risks
for a diseases uh possible treatments
involving
estrogen or progesterone which play a
role in modulating menstrual cycles
and menopause could reverse the effects
of menopause
opening a revolutionary pathway for the
treatment of
neurodegenerative diseases
so to talk a little bit about female
aging in general
so menopause is the end of a female's
menstrual cycle and fertility in which
the
ovaries no longer produce estrogen uh
and progesterone so humans undergo
menopause
but another organism that also undergoes
menopause
are rats so in this uh
research project uh we use data
from rats and so they follow
the same the similar uh menopause
uh phase as humans in which first at
about
six months for rats uh they undergo
premenopause
in which they have the normal estrous
cycles and then after that they
transition to
perimenopause at around nine months in
which the cycles are real
irregular but have not completely
stopped and then after that with some
time within those nine months
they transition into menopause
and then uh at about 15 months
there at post menopause and so post
menopause in humans
is basically the year mark from the
final cycle
and so that's basically the transitional
phases of menopause in fats
so for in terms of the aging of the
female brain
so far we know that there is
as the brain ages there is an increased
immune response
but we'd like to take a look at the
overall
um effects as well so
to transition on to the data set
distribution uh for my
study so so far there
so in my study there are six
groups with six samples each so there is
the female rat
at six months which we've abbreviated as
reg 6m
and then there's the female rat at nine
months with the normal
cycle then nine months with an irregular
cycle
nine months an acyclic then
nine months at obx and
16 months and they are
acyclic so
basically the ovx is important
because it acts as a control group in
which it highlights the most important
clinical
features of estrogen deficiency
induced or post-menopausal conditions
so to summarize my research question and
hypothesis
so understanding the genes expressed
differently in the progressive stages of
female aging
and menopause can help us understand the
risks for near degeneration
and pathways to target in order to treat
neurodegeneration such as alzheimer's
disease for women
so there were a couple of questions that
came up
from this so firstly how does the age or
time of the onset of menopause affect
the transcriptomic
expression and which pathways are
affected
are there biomarkers and menopausal
women that
are menopausal females that helps us
identify their risk for certain
neurodegenerative disorders and how does
the expression differ
in over-activized specimens and regular
specimens and can this lead to insights
on the onset of neurodegenerative
disease
and so then then comes my central
question
in what are the effects of the onset of
menopause on the transcriptomic profile
of the aging female brain
so for my methodology
i had to compare six groups
so i then used principal component
analysis
differential gene expression analysis uh
to identify the significant genes and i
used hierarchical clustering um
then uh i looked at the significantly
expressed genes and
uh did functional annotation on david
and and richer to visualize the
uh expressed pathways or the pathways
that are upregulated and down regulated
such as neuroinflammation
or neurodegeneration etc and relating
the expression to each other to draw
conclusions
and analyze which genes are
underexpressed um
or overexpressed in the six groups
so firstly um with pca i compared
the regular groups versus the acyclic
groups and the regular versus irregular
and i got these pca plots
in which there is a divergence
between the regular and acyclic and the
regular and
uh irregular and so what i did
is i basically for with these
um uh plots i
formed uh my plan for doing differential
expression in which i
split it into regular versus acyclic
and regular versus irregular so
with further pca using
the significant genes we can see that
there are
two clusters and there's also a
divergence
between the regular groups and the
overectomized group
with the two clusters and also
through differential expression i
obtained um
these two plots showing the significant
genes
and these are also other plots obtained
by differential expression
um so for the path to summarize the
pathways
that were upregulated and down regulated
so for regular versus
um irregular uh and regular versus
acyclic
the pathways that were up regulated were
related to
the immune system and the pathways that
were down regulated
um were related to uh
the mitochondria and neurodegenerative
disorders such as oxidative
phosphorylation
alzheimer's and things like that
so they share 583 genes down regulated
in 550
genes upregulated and so the
downregulation is the oxidative
phosphorylation
um alzheimer's and parkinson's so things
related to mitochondrial dysfunction
and the pathways that are upregulated
were
zinc and metal binding which are all
related to the
immune system
so i also did hierarchical clustering
and in the dendrograms
uh we can see that there they're two
that the um regular
and the acyclic groups and the regular
and irregular groups
um are separated into two clusters
showing that
they are indeed different
um and also uh through the pathway
analysis
visual visualized um on and richer
um we can see uh for the regular versus
irregular
um which pathways are upregulated um
which are
down regulated and same thing for
regular versus acyclic which pathways
are upregulated
and which pathways um are downregulated
so for my conclusion
and discussion so
firstly i found that
there is a clear distinction between the
transcriptomics
of the regular rats shifting to
irregular and
acyclic phases so our analysis clearly
indicates that there's an impact on the
transcriptomics of the rat
especially in relation to the
mitochondrial function leading to near
degenerative diseases such as
alzheimer's and parkinson's disease
and thus supporting current pathologies
and so with the upregulation of
zinc regulated pathways the immune
response was heightened
and it's also evident that menopause and
not only age is a factor for the
differential expression due to the
divergence between
the over-rectimized and the regular
groups thus controlling for age and
signific
signifying a difference between the
regular
and post-menopausal conditions and so
the study sheds light on
the targeting of possible treatments for
neurodegenerative diseases caused by
oxidative stress and through
understanding
that the transitioning of menopause
plays a role in
exacerbating oxidative stress damaging
the mitochondria
the direct hormones modulating menopause
can be controlled and so once the root
cause of the oxidative stress
is removed the damaged mitochondrial
membrane actually
is able to bounce back to original
condition
which may be revolutionary for near
degenerative recovery
the possible limitations of the study
include the sample size
and the data collection procedures which
i was unable to do myself
and it's also based on only rat samples
and it's not validated on human samples
yet
so further exploration on the lack of
estrogen and progesterone themselves
require
exploration and so that's for further
research i'd like to generate a
controlled data set
with menopausal rats supplemented with
estrogen and progesterone
to investigate the effects as well as
investigate
this phenomenon in humans
so thank you for this opportunity to
present my
project and i'm open to any questions
that you have
thank you so much nitra that was an
amazing presentation too
good work so i have one question can we
conclude from this
project that every woman who enters her
menopausal stage
would have chances of getting
neurodegenerative disorder or can we not
put it in this way
um we can say that there is
well the thing is that we can't uh
really conclude
uh we can't really say anything in
conclusive terms that
every single woman because firstly this
has to be
validated um in humans because this is
this project is currently done in rats
but we can say
that there is a possible chance uh
of that phenomenon to occur and so
through doing extra
through doing further research on this
phenomenon
in humans we might be able to make
that conclusion
thank you and also we do have one
question from
youtube online streaming uh prima is
asking
that does menopause occur in all female
organisms at some particular time
or age period in which this mechanisms
take place
um i'm not sure if menopause happens
in every organism but i do know
that it happens in most mammals
um and so menopause it typically
is towards the end of the
fertility cycle for uh
organisms that do have menopause
because of the general aging so i hope
that answers
uh that question so because rats are
mammals and humans are also mammals
menopause occurs
also we do have one more question from
zulfiqar mehdi she says you have given
the nice talk
and also can you name some noteworthy
targets with therapeutic advantage in
neurodegenerative diseases
um so so far
for neurodegenerative diseases um like
for alzheimer's
the way that they treat it is by
treating the symptoms like for example
they target acetylcholine
or dopamine but that only targets
the symptoms whereas for the
root cause which could be
related to menopause um they could
possibly
uh target the pathway involving
um estrogen and progesterone uh
modulation because with menopause
estrogen
the difference between um you know
regular cycling and in menopause is that
estrogen and progesterone
are not produced and so possibly
um through adding through adding
estrogen and progesterone back into the
pathway
um there might be some therapeutic
advantage to that
but since it hasn't been tested we don't
really know for sure
okay can it be any protein
um or gene regulation no we haven't i
haven't
investigated that in my uh study
uh thanks neeta for answering that
question uh what i think for
zulfiqar is maybe you should go through
some literature review
on this particular topic of neural
degeneration and protein regulation
there are many on ncbi
because this question is very broad in
itself and it just cannot be answered
from one perspective or one project
of view so that would be helpful for you
i guess and if you need some more
literature review you can surely reach
out to me i'll help you thank you
any more questions for nitro
okay if there are any more questions you
can put it down in the chat box thank
you so much nedra for sharing with us
your wonderful project
we have a lot from you to learn as well
thank you for being with us we are glad
to have you
thank you can i yeah thank you uh
sonalika
uh uh over here sodalika would tell you
about the upcoming events and webinars
from pine bar tech
sonaliga you may share your screen thank
you
thank you so much ruthvi and thank you
so much urja and natra for such
wonderful presentations and showcasing
your work as well i hope it would have
helped a number of people here
to uh know more about how transcriptomic
data could be analyzed and visualized as
well
so let let me just quickly take you
through
our portal that is learn.comicslogic and
if you have already signed up to the
portal it's great
if you have not done so far uh here is
the link you can
sign up now and those who have already
signed up
i would request them to please update
their profile
and by updating profile i mean please
add your profile
picture and also link in your social
now this is because we want the correct
name of yours
uh in your profile because that would be
reflecting in your certificates as well
and to have your social links it's just
because we have been having recruiters
over the time and we share good profiles
with them
and also we would be featuring uh you
on your performance on over our social
so we would want your social link
too and now coming to the
research fellowship program
so nitra and urja were a part of a
research fellowship program
and they did such wonderful projects in
the program itself
so even if you wish to be a part of the
research fellowship program and carry
out your independent research project
under mental guidance you can register
yourself
on this page the link i've shared with
you all you need to do is just register
yourself
to the page and you can also go through
the page to
clear your doubts and we have answered
few frequently asked questions over here
and also we have added the
progress like what would be the steps
you would have to
follow in the research fellowship
program
and what all you would have to go
through you can go through
the program page as well and also i'm
sharing with you
a blog which you can refer to learn more
about the research fellowship program
and also you can go through the projects
as of nathra and urja we have other
projects
as well by our ex-research fellows
so you can go to their projects as well
and learn what they did
and many of you we also give
scholarships to students who are worth
it so here is the scholarship
link i would request the students to
also fill in the scholarship application
so that we can go through your
application and
obviously give a scholarship because uh
i
because we think those who are really
into research
and are looking forward for great
research work they
should be supported with the scholarship
so here is the form and we would be
looking forward to your registrations
and applications as well
now coming to our upcoming program that
is on precision
medicine this program would be starting
on july
6th it would be a month training and
would end on august 5th
and uh we have a free webinar tomorrow
at 8 00 pm where we would be discussing
about the program we would be discussing
the session details as well and what all
would be covered
and why this program is necessary so
those who want to learn more about the
program now
and also register themselves here is the
link for you you can just go to this
program page here all the details of the
program
uh is mentioned and also the session
details
uh with their topics and what all would
be covered as mentioned in the program
page now taking forward to the social
media
i really want that we all stay connected
and also you stay updated
with all our ongoing and upcoming
programs and projects because we see
that bioinformatics
is changing the uh era of research and
we need not miss out on
any such opportunity which could help us
learn more about the bioinformatics
tools
and also different sorts of advances in
the research
so to stay updated you can follow us on
linkedin
also they had shared the links of
our telegram and whatsapp groups so here
uh
here is the linkedin group link as well
you can be a part of a group and also we
have
so many experts as part of a group so
they would be there to help you as well
and on facebook we are by the name of
pine biotech you can
follow us there as well so we have
spread all across
across so that you have no issue
finding us anywhere and you can stay in
touch with us
and get updates on all our upcoming
programs and if you have any doubts you
can anytime
mail me at marketing at the rate
pine dot bio and i would be there to
help you out
thank you so much for conducting such a
wonderful
session and we have the psionic session
every thursday so we would be meeting
you again
next thursday let's see who we have as
speakers
we would be updating you all with it
soon thank you everyone for being a part
of
us for the webinar and uh those who have
any doubts
uh regarding urjas or nathra's projects
you can
mail them and get in touch with them and
if any
other query you have regarding the
programs or the
uh the registrations or applications or
scholarships
uh your you can anytime mail me i'll be
my
email id which i've shared with you
thank you so much everyone
thank you ruthvi
thank you sanadika bye
bye everyone take care bye